your wife hold it
does my wife hold it when I pay you not
anymore
I don't know I don't like it
some guys in here
and here's flying the ship I don't like
that
and and anybody who's ever had it done
for them they're not responsible with it
they she thought she was Luke
Skywalker she was like
she hit everything dude she's just like
this is so much fun I do this all the
time I'm like you
bathroom all the time
monkey what are you doing
because when it's blasted she's like
it's much more like a toy
you can do other things with it when
it's hard you can really only do one
thing with it but when it's plastic
there's a bunch of different stuff to do
with it I'm like not really what are we
saying right now
sorry about that uh why did you only
appointed me both of us are up here yeah
are you because because I have a hard
enough time making in the bowl just by
myself I don't need somebody else's help
yeah
unfortunate sight into your life right
now but okay
you do that
I think I have like two or three holes
down there I'm not sure Jesus
I should probably get that checked out I
was just gonna say what the
[Music]
yo dude but that would be weird if you
did have three and you never knew which
hole it was going to come out of like a
mini golf course
what did you say like a mini golf course
you know it has one hole there and one
there and you're like I don't know which
one the ball is coming out of it every
morning you're like you have to kind of
three aim it at once
but it's like a sprinkler yeah dude that
would be amazing yeah
any other questions